hello there guys and welcome to another
video so this is going to be a quick but
exciting video as we have a trailer
update regarding the obi-wan kenobi
limited series so the making star wars
youtube channel shared a rumor
suggesting that the first trailer for
obi-wan kenobi will arrive on either
wednesday march 9 or thursday march 10.
according to the sources the site saw
evidence of shots from the trailer that
looks too good to be fake the person
that showed them the images claimed that
the trade level debut on the 9th while
another rumor indicated that it would
come one day later so it reads here we
had a source a new source a source i'm
not familiar with that's why we're
putting this as a rumor and we're trying
to be very clear about this being a
rumor but they showed evidence from a
kenobi trailer we've seen evidence that
these are shot from the kenobi trailer
and are nothing amazing but the new
costume things you realistically could
not just go out and fake and this person
claims that the trailer will drop on the
9th if you remember we had heard another
rumor before that it was coming on the
10th so this other person comes with
pictures going it's on the 9th if these
rumors are to be believed obi-wan kenobi
is getting ready to make a big splash in
the foreseeable future should the
trailer debut on either march 9th or
10th it would arrive only two and a half
months before the series begins
streaming on disney plus for comparison
the first trailer for the buku boba fett
arrived less than two months before his
first episode while there was a close
two and a half month delay before the
first trailer and debut for season one
of the mandalorian so let's say the
trailer does release next week which
fingers crossta does how much will
lucasfilm show on this trailer if you do
get a trailer my money is that it will
be a teaser trailer so i don't think
lucasfilm will show us too much but just
enough to get us excited i mean pretty
much anything could get us excited at
this point we just want to see some
footage from this show it's probably the
most anticipated star wars series to
date so i guess we just have to wait
until next week to see if we'll get our
first look at the show so fingers
crossed let me know in the comment
section below what you want to see from
this trailer and if you haven't already
please like and subscribe and turn
notifications on to show your support
thanks for watching